we have an update on owen stalker
it's just a short little video 41
minutes and
um a little quick a little little quick
one
a little quick v-log a little v-log from
uh cat i am goddess and queen bee
vs bear whatever uh this is b
versus bear it's a 40 minute video let's
see let's see maybe she's
gotten better maybe she's taken some of
this um
criticism to heart what's going on with
big bears stalker
today because i was so exhausted
i haven't been getting enough sleep i've
been sleeping in my car
and i needed a shower i hadn't
had one for days so i went to try to get
a room
another grabbler situation
my uh the catchphrase how to get three
different rooms and
every one was worse than the last one
they didn't even have phone in there
to call the office to tell them about
why would you need a phone in 2021
i listen in the last two years i've
probably stayed at
25 hotels i've used the phone twice
yeah yeah once in a while you go beep
hey the ac is not working but i've never
used those phones
the problem is i had to keep walking or
driving over there and also what like
what five-star
like [ __ ] uh uh uh what kind of
[ __ ]
uh beautiful resort hotels is she
expecting to find in sandpoint idaho
like that's a truck stop town like yeah
owen moved there because i'm sure you
get land cheap and
you can't you're sure there are people
in the community they're good folks and
stuff but
it's not like people are heading to
sandpoint like
that's one of those nowhereville areas
where flying there's probably more
expensive because they're like
we don't run a lot of planes like you're
gonna have to connect in salt lake city
and then go to [ __ ] boise
like i'm sure it's just one of those
place it's truckerville
and it's quite a ways because it's in
two different places at this
roadway in roadway
they didn't have water don't stay at a
road away and never stay in a roadway
state of the roadway it's not it's the
worst
i fly even he said oh it'll be better in
the room
there was none non-existent i couldn't
even join the wi-fi
so after the third room i was so
upset and everything i just went ahead
and took a shower
and then went down and showed him
uh a picture that i took of the blinds
that i tried to lower
so the light wouldn't come in and the
damn things were full i'm going to skip
ahead from the uh
hotel stuff by the way malevolent bison
i said the red carpet in isn't as nice
as it sounds either no it's oh
red the red carpet in isn't good is
george clooney not staying there
am i not going to get a glimpse at
hollywood celebs
staying at the red carpet george
zimmerman's not staying there
i was in there and stuff because i
hadn't been taking my sub supplements
i can't do any of this a lot of this
stuff i was doing
as far as being crazy detoxing and
fasting and all that which has
helped to really decrest my pineal gland
you've what royce you've never decrusted
your pineal gland
what no mike i can say i've never
decrested my pineal gland
have you no okay no my pineal gland is
probably very crusty
you gotta de-crust that bad boy people
seem to want to make fun of because
they're so
stupid well that's us so if you're going
to make fun of me i'm going to call you
stupid
that's honestly because the people that
are supporting me
are not coming at me like this they're
not supporting you ma'am
they're making fun of you and making it
seem like they're supporting you yeah
and they're sending you money so that
you can
act crazier and keep going they want you
to accelerate
you're now then you're see you got to
understand ma'am
uh a couple months back we lost
baked alaska r.i.p after that murder he
committed to dc i remember when he
when he beat when he savagely beat a
capital police officer to death with a
fire extinguisher
he paved his skull and it was gross um
so we'll him we'll see him no more
um bait's gone he's gonna go do
40 years to life um if he's lucky for
a road trip we lost lolz we've lost
stop speeding we lost johnny boston
we lost a lot of guys ip2 is
ip2 never dies but right now it's going
through a bit of a a valley
if you will and uh we're doing what we
can ma'am
you're the only one keeping irl in the
spirit of irl alive
that's the only reason people and if
you'll learn anything from irl
the people that support you hate your
guts nobody actually likes you
they want it to end oh somebody said
stop speeding's right on right now yeah
but you know
point is it it's ebb and flow and right
now it's an
ebb and people are looking at you too
which is why we've been telling people
please do not
i don't know if you've gotten weird
emails but i know some people have been
trying to make it look
like we're interacting with this lady oh
no yeah
quite the opposite we've said don't and
i've yelled at every single person like
[ __ ] [ __ ] knock it off like
this is i just want to watch
and i got way more support at least
three times as much support as i got
these trolls and shills and whatever
that are
coming at me to make fun of me
so they can reject what i have to say
their loss
i'm here to share share my knowledge
who's the wealthier person me or
owen he's got money yes
me yes yes yes owen i'll take owen
ah yes point on the board for me that
was easy
which i don't have i don't even have a
[ __ ] phone
and the other night i in standpoint
i went to a back road where it was
really dark
and deserted at the end of the road or
you know i mean it was kind of started
where the i saw a guy rolling a corpse
down the hill
oh boy this lady is not so i'm pretty
sure there wasn't a guy rolling a corpse
down a hill may i ask a question then
ma'am
did you happen to notify law enforcement
because that's what i would do right
like you saw somebody getting rid of a
body
you're driving out to dinner you go i
gotta make sure call the cops about that
hey i think i saw somebody dumping
something suspect did you call the cops
ma'am or are you crazy
i'm going to say the latter okay i see
point on the board for royce i'm going
to go with the latter one
right we're tied
so anyway i got it was snowy nice
it's really cold and i slid into
the ditch and had to be towed out
i was sitting there in the dark not
knowing how am i going to deal with this
i had no phone no wi-fi
nothing that i could reach out to
anybody
and i'm i'm just stuck there in the dark
and then finally somebody drove down the
road
this girl young girl who
saw that i was stuck and she said i'll
go get when i thought
she said her dad but it turns out it was
her boyfriend
and he came up and told me
there's a tow truck that'll be here in
20 minutes
he paid for the tow truck and then
they left and then came back
and gave me a 50
gift certificate to mcdonald's which
that's a lot of mcdonald's
now it is oh you're right probably not
as much back in the day with dollar menu
though
back in the day 50 bucks would have fed
you for a month yeah i appreciate but i
won't eat their food so i will
pay that forward what an ungrateful so
you have no money
you have no food what an ungrateful
[ __ ] and now you're not even gonna use
it
dude yeah like seriously do you know
look i know we all agree mcdonald's is
not good for you
of course you shouldn't eat it all the
time sometimes it sucks whatever but
dude when i got out of jail the [ __ ]
dude that mcdonald's was some of the
greatest
food i've ever eaten in my life how dare
you late how dare you
put on airs while you're sleeping in a
car in sandpoint idaho
and also what else is around there
because i had to go to a town
similar to sand point for christmas
where
you got a couple of choices man and it's
mcdonald's it's mcdonald's or
the other mcdonald's so what are you
gonna eat like
the fact that this woman is like oh i
don't really eat that stuff
you're homeless in a car freezing to
death i
there were times in my life i would have
sucked a dick for some mcdonald's that's
how [ __ ] rough it was out there
you know like where somebody just went
here i got you an extra mcdouble or
whatever and some fries where you go
oh man thank you so much and this
this woman i don't eat it sorry or
making fun of me or whatever
i will give them a couple of
opportunities
to come around with three strikes you're
out i will
start to just
i don't want to use the word ban i just
do not want to be abused anymore
so i will go and tell you now about my
history
of abuse and why i'm an advocate for
people
being abused as a child
i was molested sexually incested by
five family member members
one and one member that was the
boyfriend of my aunt
who um that was one of the last abuses i
left before i left new york when i was
nine years old
but it was happening some from at least
the time of two and maybe earlier
but i have memories back to two so it
could have been at 18 months or who
knows
my stepdad who was i was told was my
father who is not my father
my father's wallace stang wally
wally just like oh the robot the trash
cleaning robot right well it's also a
molesting robot
a trash cleaning molesting robot correct
you know that's gonna
next time i watch that movie it's really
gonna change the meaning for me
pics are super weird now dude i guess
apparently they're very
uh they're trying to get that netflix
money yeah bigger he would probably say
oh somebody that gives him more money's
a bigger supporter
financially maybe but i was going around
that being said i want to make an
announcement to uh
i'm selling my goodwill at this point so
from now on at least on night wave
uh i will like whoever gives me the most
money the most
seems fair i get down with that yeah i
mean we can't sit here and claim to be
capitalists and then go
oh let's everybody could play on their
merits
no you can buy my love this lady's got a
good point her dad was right
point telling people about his channel
and check him out
and now the very one of the very first
people that i told that i ran
into at the store a different store
that she worked at and told her don't
trust him now
i have to un every time i see somebody
that i know that i told this to but i
told it to a lot of strangers
to um i told a lot of strangers there's
a hollywood
comedian here making a fool of myself i
guess but
um ma'am i don't think the owen thing is
a reason people you're making you're
making a fool of yourself i think
there's several other reasons
my intentions were pure and i was
supporting this man
that is now people
for their money their hard-earned money
whoa
whoa no no she's got a point and look
i'm gonna cooperate this i mean you know
this poor woman she's out here owen
benjamin is literally
everybody
little bit of cash they're sending to
him he doesn't need it you need it more
than him
then why were you sending him cash for
so long lady
so back to being in molasses and also
the thing i always bring up too like
it's this is your own bitterness you're
angry that he
that he rejected you and now you're
furious and you'll do anything you can
to take them down
i deal with similar people like this on
a regular basis
it's not enough to go man that guy sucks
i'm gonna make a video criticizing him
it's always like
then it graduates to you screaming in
the chat why is everyone giving this guy
money you shouldn't be doing this
and everybody's like hey stupid beat it
we're having fun
and then that's not enough so then it's
like this this kind of [ __ ] man is like
the new
internet attitude this is how people are
she happens to be crazy and like
an exaggerated version of all these
people but it's the same attitude it's
just like
why are you guys supporting this guy and
it's like
i don't have to explain to myself to you
crazy lady who lives in a car
who's too good to use her 50 free
mcdonald's gift card that makes me the
most mad out of this video i'm
so happy to keep bringing it up that
pisses me off i have an apartment
and i have a car and i have money and if
somebody gave me a 50 gift card to
mcdonald's
i would stop right aft right after the
show i'd be going yes please
20 nuggets please thank you thank you
i'll be using my gift card
[Laughter]
oh wait i'm going to ask my friend
if he wants me to announce his name so
for
anyone that would like to have readings
from him you can help support him by
getting a reading he does really
excellent
work he's very knowledgeable it's
coddington bear
kidding about a lot of things and he
finds out your future by
like looking at your dumps and reading
the lines oh no you're dumps
a dump of dump fortune teller it's like
the lines in your hand but he
yeah he literally waits for you to take
a dump and then he goes uh that's your
fortune line right there and it's
interacting with your lifeline
if you look next to the corn in between
the peanuts
very young but he is between the corn
and the
was were you eating seaweed yesterday
were you
having wraps or sushi or something
just wisdom beyond his years that he
doesn't even know
so i would support getting him supported
so you support him then yeah but let
these people support who they want to
support
so if anyone is interested in in that
getting readings for themselves i will
promote him but i will ask him first if
he wants me to announce it
so i just want people to know where i'm
coming from
you know we know washington right
that i am an advocate for people being
abused
i've worked at um the uh
um rehab places where
are you sure you weren't in a rehab
place did they tell you you work there
did they let you like do things so you
felt like a productive member of society
really
i ran therapy
group therapy
and i also um had group
therapy sessions with battered woman at
another place at mariposa's women's
center
in california these places were in
california when i lived in california
and there's another place owen was that
i was
we were both in california but i got i
left there
in in 95 to get the [ __ ] out of
california just as he was coming
in to be further programmed
and then he's in immersed in hollywood
you're gonna believe a hollywood he left
celebrities over
now he's a dealer celebrity when you
were worshiping him you thought he was
jesus christ you were showing up at the
post office
wanting to be the nanny of his kids and
now he's a dealer celebrity but that's
that's how these people are man it's
this dude it's this whole parasocial
[ __ ] it's it's the new psychology of
the internet these people watch you for
hours every day
they start to experience it more
differently than you do because you're
just
you're on a screen talking but they're
spending all this time with you and they
start getting [ __ ] crazy and then
when you reject them
they go mental we've had it happen not
to this extent
but it ha these people can't take
rejection and then it becomes like a oh
well you're a piece of [ __ ] anyway
you it's the same thing whether it's
owen dealing with this lady
whether it's me dealing with my creepy
stalkers or whether it's some chick
online
that has a guy that dms them all the
time going hey hey i like you a lot
hey i donated to your twitch stream hey
hey what's going on
hey if you ever want to talk and every
time the girl tweets something vaguely
said though
if you want to talk sometime you know
i'm here hey
hey what's up you know i really like you
right and then one day they just start
getting a wall of text you [ __ ]
ugly fat [ __ ] you [ __ ] get cancer you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they're like
dude i never said anything to this guy
people just
fixate man and there's no more real
world anymore
there's nothing in the real world for
them to cling to or even real world san
francisco which is would at least give
them a distraction
it's mtv's fault really yes frankly we
should all sue viacom
somebody like me that has all this
experience and wisdom i'm 30 years
older than him don't you think in 30
more years he'd know some more [ __ ] yeah
but the thing is right
you're 30 years older than him but
you're
you're living in a car in san point
idaho he
sleeps in a warm bed with his wife and
his family
there's nothing i hate more than people
that use their age to lord over people
like hey look royce all right i'm 50
years old i think i got a little
something on you in terms of knowledge
and you're like you've been to prison
now except my mcdonald's gift card i'm
hungry hey guy at the checkers with a
neck tattoo
i get you're older but also you were in
jail for a long time
but he's misleading people like he
misled me
all the way here i misled me she thinks
that
is talking to her directly he did it
i spent thousands of dollars i didn't
have
to follow this dream that he
set up set me up for so it's like the
grateful you're following the grateful
dead except in this case you're
following somebody who was on a tbs
sitcom
sounds really sad lady and only to have
this happen to me
now i understand why he was so scared
and i know why he was scared because a
crazy lady was screaming at him at the
post office
i would be scared
it's not because of his knowledge he is
very
he's very highly intelligent but so am i
i'm way more intelligent than him
yeah normally people living in a car and
throwing away mcdonald's gift cards and
driving into a ditch
and uh having to use toilets that look
like the [ __ ]
or usually intelligent people and i
scare the [ __ ] out of him
because of that intelligence and because
of my light
her light his merkaba ain't nothing like
mine
i believe that that is a turkish dish
that you eat with tzatziki sauce pretty
sure are we now fighting over
who's more uh who's better at making
mediterranean food i think so
i don't know what merkaba is but it does
sound like turkish food it does sound
good though
get some macabre and i like falafel
nothing better
if he even has one i don't know i
haven't been
physically around him that's why people
can't be around but you have been
physically around him at the post office
you admitted to it they can't handle the
truth
literally oh absolute star goes no you
idiots
is a tool song oh that is
it does sound like a tool song really
cannot handle the truth
and neither can owen i saw the fear in
those pretty blue eyes
big bear as he reached in his pocket
asking would he want money money like he
could pay me off to get rid of me
that right there says a whole lot then
the next time
um i'm in the post office in front of
him
at the counter putting in my change of
address to there
yes i need to change my address from
washington dc to a
1998 toyota camry
care of love's truck stop yes thank you
point idaho
you think amazon delivers there just
have the mitch just have the guy drop it
up the guy the kid greg he works at the
front counter he knows me
yeah that's fine my address there is
still general delivery sandpoint idaho
83864 just like his
post office box but mine is a general
delivery so if you want to contact me
you can call
you can contact me there i have no
physical address i'm living in my car
i have my email address you can email me
i
may not be able to respond to everybody
because i'm starting to get emails from
all over the world
um my
address is cassie 3333
at gmail.com he doesn't announce at
least it wasn't an ao
at least it wasn't an aol site so i'll
give her that much
address my phone number is 808.
i'm skipping i'm skipping it i just
skipped ahead i skipped it i got it
i skipped the head i skipped that have
like a spiritual connection
i'm like the the mother that he lost
when he was a child he didn't know his
mother
and so i i have a little sauce this is
all in your
head lady that's the issue
this is all in your mind
from my boys in the gambia and they're
sisters
so um anyway
i i wanted to give more of my background
so people know where i'm coming from
that i
so i'm an advocate for those being
abused
and now i'm being abused so i have to be
an advocate for my
she's a regular paul heyman self but i
have so much
information to share especially about
the nano poisoning and i'll probably get
struck down i got poisoning again i
remember that
let me tell you something mike if i had
a [ __ ] nickel for every time nano
poisoning affected me
and be rich you know what's funny though
is i actually did google it one night
when i was watching this ladies video
and um
it is a real thing nano poisoning yeah
nano poisoning is a real thing
what is it it but it's it's rare it's
when you get
um okay so there's um uh forget what
it's called it's some kind of like
powder
powderized carbon that comes out it's
not
soot but it's like soot but it's these
little nano particles of carbon that
build up into a giant [ __ ]
like thing of soot and if you get
breathe in those dust clouds uh there's
some kind of other
like weird like one of those chemical
compounds that you can breathe in those
are considered like
they're very tiny aerosolized metal
particles that you can breath
but like people that get poisoned by
these nano poison things these are
people that work in like
industrial centers and factories and
they work in chemical plants and
like we're not she's saying nano poisons
because it is a real thing but it's like
that's a thing you'd have to be working
in technology to get [ __ ]
exp or working on an oil rig but she's
just taking it as nano
they like these crazy people love words
that sound like they're in will smith
futuristic movies
and they like using those words to
indulge their horseshit
i have nano poisoning and get jiggy with
it syndrome it's the worst exactly
please believe me you don't have to
believe me it's your loss
but i'm telling you i'll be talking more
about this
because it's all the world leaders i'm
calling trump a female
i'm calling justin trudeau a female i'm
called
fauci a female i'm calling bill gates a
female i'm going to be doing an
impersonation video of bill gates
i can't wait when is that video coming
out
all right guys so this is bill gates but
like if he lived in his car
okay it's great i'm excited i am cold
it's really good it's a good book aids
man because i can make myself look like
a mama hairdresser
but i'm also an artist also drawing many
many nude bodies
i know a man when i see a man and i know
a woman
hips don't lie shakira shakira is a man
then i'm gay bro i'm super gay now i'm
the gayest gay oh no
i have a lot of thinking to do oh man
all the uh victoria's secret models
are men why is it called victoria's
secret
it's a secret all right she's trying out
bits now she is she's doing her
type five is she writing materials we're
going to tie five should be in the idaho
improv this weekend
yeah it's like yeah victoria's secret
it's like what's the secret babe
too bad no people don't see it i have
such clear cognizance
from all the fasting and detoxing i've
done and if you stop eating the [ __ ]
food and start
detoxing you might clearly talk to
yourself right into living in your car
and freezing to death
and and getting having to rely on the
kindness of young couples to pay for
your tow truck bill
any word on that mcdonald's gift card
any word on it do we know where it is
this is it's weird man when you see
people like this and they're like i
am doing good doing well
your pineal gland and start to see some
of this [ __ ] that's going on
sorry for my language but i can't help
it
um i was in an explosion that i
told them it was going to happen i was
above an electrical room
and a place where i lived and i told her
now she has the origin of a spider-man
villain well she was
unbreakable
i'm like at least three times
that something is going to go down
something's going to happen down in that
electrical room do something
yeah it exploded all right and i was my
room was right above it they had
yeah but it's called living in an
apartment like for instance okay
for a good example um the ac
unit that's downstairs the big outside
one
condenser that [ __ ] is going i mean i
can tell you
if you came over and heard it you'd go
does it clank really loud when it turns
on it does the
oh yeah that's about to go that
compresses it and then it goes but i'm
like all right so
i know for fact and i've already emailed
him and i said hey by the way heads up
that thing outside's gonna go at some
point now
when it does blow they'll have to
replace it which i will give my
apartment they're very quick about
fixing [ __ ] i'll give them that much
so fix it will be back up and running on
time do i get to then go around and
claim to be clairvoyant
yeah because i because i because i saw a
clear issue that was coming like she's
like i was above that room yeah and you
probably had power issues in the
building and you probably went
that room down there something's gonna
happen one day you're not a psychic
it's called troubleshooting
all right look we we we got it but yeah
that ac is definitely good
at least like twice a day you'll hear
kick on it
like a minute and then it starts going
and you're like oh that thing like if
you were a homeowner and you heard that
you'd be going
[ __ ] that's gonna suck
all right let's uh read some of these
here
uh johnny bologna my youtube